[Música]
pasamos a nuestra sección de salud con
más Romero salamar Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela Hablamos hoy del
acceso de desigual a la morfina este
medicamento contra el dolor básico para
los cuidados médicos pero a pesar de ser
muy básico pues no está para todo el
mundo exactamente ese es el problema que
señala precisamente un informe de la OMS
que se publicó la semana pasada a
finales de la semana pasada y
básicamente dice que los países de
ingresos más altos consumen mucho más
morfina hasta 63 veces más que los
países de ingresos más bajos y otro dato
para resumir un poco este panorama el
10% de los países más ricos tienen
acceso al 90% del medicamento este que
se usa digamos de forma muy común no en
muchos ámbitos de la medicina para
comprender mejor Qué implicaciones tiene
esta noticia y estas desigualdades nos
acompaña desde Ciudad de México la
doctora Roxana Trejo médico epidemióloga
especialista en salud pública y a partir
de hoy también una de las nuevas voces
de asesores científicos que acompañan a
France 24 doctora Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos empecemos por lo básico
Cuál es el uso médico de la morfina
Cuáles son las recomendaciones En qué
ocasiones se administra
Hola cómo están Buen día Un saludo a
todos ustedes y gracias por la
invitación Bueno la morfina es parte de
los opioides es un fármaco que se
utiliza de manera importante para
mitigar el dolor se utiliza también para
el tema de disnea cuando los pacientes
tienen dificultad respiratoria para
quitar esa ansiedad que se puede tener y
también hay un tema muy importante que
hoy se está impulsando que son los
paliativos los cuidados paliativos
cuando una persona un paciente tiene una
enfermedad terminal en donde tenemos que
dar los cuidados para que tenga una
calidad de vida pues lo mejor posible
durante sus pues su periodo de de final
de la enfermedad entonces es un es un
fármaco muy importante que como comentas
mar pues hoy se está viendo en jaque ya
tiene varios años pero después de este
comunicado de la OMS Pues todos estamos
atentos a que las población Perdón los
sistemas de salud estén este haciendo
acciones doctora Roxana un gusto
saludarla y Quiero preguntarle Cuáles
son las consecuencias sobre la salud de
no tener el acceso a este medicamento
Hola Cómo estás Buen día Pues el
principal problema es que las personas
sufren durante este periodo si no
tenemos este acceso a medicamento por
ejemplo en México necesitaríamos más o
menos unas doscientas toneladas y así
diferentes países latinoamérica y al
final en mi país llegan más o menos 700
kilogramos nada más entonces la
dificultad de poder atender a estos
pacientes y que sufren durante su
tránsito de la enfermedad pues es muy
importante creo que solamente se
visualiza con estas personas que están
enfermas pero en realidad todos los que
estamos alrededor que estamos en un tema
de salud podemos observar la dificultad
que tienen para poder los médicos y el
sistema de salud dar Pues un eficiente
tratamiento para ellos es el sufrimiento
es importante y creo que es ahí donde
debemos de enfocarnos el tema de
humanización también lo debemos de sumar
cada vez impulsa más que el sistema de
salud seamos pues tenemos un tema
humanizado no solamente se ve la
enfermedad sino Lo que siente el
paciente doctor yo le quería preguntar
por estas razones de las desigualdades
no la OMS hablaba un poco de las faltas
de dinero por supuesto de las trabas
legales a también de las dificultades de
las cadenas de distribución de estos
medicamentos pero le quería preguntar si
también los países con más ingresos
hacen un sobre uso de este tipo de
medicamento y más en un contexto por
ejemplo donde en Estados Unidos donde
medicamentos como la morfina este
opioide también ha sido la puerta de
entrada a muchos otros problemas de
salud como los problemas de adicciones
por ejemplo al fentanilo o a otros
medicamentos Entonces le quería
preguntar eso si realmente hay un sobre
uso un exceso de consumo de morfina o
medicamentos parecidos
qué buena pregunta me haces mal yo creo
que sí sí hay un más en países de primer
mundo en Estados Unidos específicamente
en donde se utiliza de una manera pues
no controlada o sea el sistema de salud
o los médicos deben de indicar este
medicamento sabemos que en Estados
Unidos se necesita una receta Pero se
tiene que tener control para estos
pacientes y creo que hay un punto
importante no solamente la cantidad que
consumen sino lo que ocurre cuando
después de que el sistema de salud deja
de dar esta receta y puede haber un tema
de adicción entonces empiezan a utilizar
otros opioides o otros a drogas para
poder suplir lo que ya por vario tiempo
han utilizado y creo que ahí se
convierte en un jaque no en donde los
pacientes deben de estar los médicos
debemos de revisar puntualmente a cada
paciente para poder indicar el fármaco
correcto a las dosis correctas y el
tiempo correcto eso es muy importante
porque si no se hace un un círculo
vicioso de adicción después se utilizan
algunos otros este medicamentos o peones
o no opioides y que al final esto
provoca pues resultados pues
catastróficos la mortalidad que existe
en Estados Unidos por la utilización de
estos fármacos es alto o sea hay que
regular la dosis se puede exceder en la
dosis si hay una mortalidad relacionada
a la utilización de estos o es
importante y el otro punto que que
comentabasmar es que los países no no
como Estados Unidos sino los que
escaseamos en el producto en todo el
continente y en otros continentes
debemos de tener políticas públicas
enfocadas a este tema para poder
soportar la necesidad que tenemos de
nuestros pacientes entonces creo que hay
que regular bien en estos países como
Estados Unidos en donde sí sí existe un
abasto hay que utilizarlo correctamente
para que también podamos dar apoyo a los
que no tenemos esa privilegio de contar
con este opioide de manera pues
importante no o con una cobertura al
cien por ciento pues doctora justamente
Cuáles son esas acciones que se
recomiendan para hacer una distribución
que sea más igualitaria y más justa del
medicamento
Pues un punto importante es que se ponga
en el centro de las políticas públicas
de cada país cada país debe de tenerlo
en su sistema de salud como algo
importante algo algo a prioritario y lo
que está ocurriendo hoy es que no ha
sido homogéneo este este tema de
política pública para que después se
tenga un recurso económico Cuando uno lo
pone en foco en cada país se genera un
recurso económico para poder o
importarlo o producirlo que creo que es
muy importante también este que estamos
muy dependientes de otra producción en
otros países y esto también nos complica
lo hemos vivido con otras situaciones
pero específicamente para los opioides
debemos tener políticas públicas para
tener un recurso económico y poder
importarlo o producirlo en cada uno de
los continentes y con esa finalidad
poder tener este fármaco que es muy
importante y después hacer un uso
correcto del fármaco para que no ocurra
como como otros países que hay unas pues
sobre uso
de este fármaco específicamente morfina
doctora pues muchas gracias por todas
esto por este análisis que nos ofrece
hoy seguro la vamos a seguir viendo aquí
en France 24 ha sido un gusto Muchas
gracias gracias a usted mar como siempre
y nos vemos mañana con más noticias
Claro que sí Ángela esta mañana hasta
mañana